Forbes came out with its list of the top
10 highest paid athletes in the world
here's the actual list that came out
with all right now okay a lot of names
that you'd expect to see I noticed
something interesting though true story
a number of athletes on the list make
more money from endorsements than from
their sport that's right look at that
right there
they make more money for selling than
for playing pretty interesting actually
Conan it's very common for example I'm
Jacques moraine the world's highest-paid
professional fencer you the highest-paid
French in the world sir what do you make
$48,000 a year but I also make three
million dollars endorsing Monaco's
number one carbonated melon liqueur
Sauve
so good yeah three million is that all
you make buddy hey Conan Karla Stapleton
highest-paying field hockey player in
the country
I make 70,000 on the field and eight
million dollars promoting this Virago
field hockey stick tape bravo field
hockey stick tape the right tape for the
job when the job is taping field hockey
sticks
that is very impressive very impressive
yeah yeah I guess that's not too shabby
but I got y'all beat Mark Jefferson Pro
bass fisherman I made $6,000 on circuit
last year but I made twenty million
dollars promote leagues
mr. ball stress squeezer screech
distressful a with mr. ball okay wait a
minute wait a minute that's just a
racquet ball with a stupid logo on it
there's no way a company would pay you
twenty million dollars to promote those
no way they do because these mr. ball is
two ounces of pure uncut cocaine inside
it you see I work for the drug lord el
Chango el tango drops thousands of these
balls off the coast of Key West when the
top brings them into Shore it's up to me
in my little boat scoop them all up then
I deliver them to a warehouse and they
return my family to meet again until
next month will not do it all over yeah
wait a minute sir you're saying they
kidnap your family every month that's
horrible yeah it's pretty stressful
that's why I squeeze this away with mr.
Bao
thank you thank you Paul
we've been working on that sketch for
four years but I think it was no yeah
yeah hundreds of thousand dollars
you